If you answered yes, then you and I are on the same wavelength. And in the
next few panels, I'm going to show you how
this particular programming construct that a multithreaded program
may execute in terms of producer and a
consumer, can actually accom, accomplished with simple read/write
atomic operations available in the instruction set of
a processor. The solution, it turns out is
surprisingly very simple. The idea is that
between p1 and p2, I'm going to introduce a
new variable, a shared variable, and that variable,
I'll call it a flag. And I'll initialize
this flag to be zero to start with.
And the agreement between these two. Producers in
consumer is that the producer will modify the
data structure that he wants to modify and
once he's done with the modification he will
set this flag to be a one. And that's
the signal to p2 that this guy is
done with the modification. Now, what is p2 doing?
Well, p2 is basically waiting. For this flag
which initial, initially the flag was initially zero. And,
and basically the processor P2 is waiting for the
flag to change from a zero to a one.
Now once p1 is done with its modification, it's going to
set this flag to a, to a one. And that's the
signal that this guy's waiting for. And as soon as this
flag changes to a one. Then he'll break out of this spin
loop here,and he is now ready to use the real structure.
And once he is done using the real structure, he can
flip it back to zero, to indicate that he is, that
he is done using it. So that the next time it the
producer wants to modify it again he can
do that. So that's sort of the solution.
Now, let's analyze the solution and see why
it works. It will just atomic reads and writes.